you know I only but only 20 years from
now can you know what the legacy of
george w bush will be because nothing is
as arrogant and as presumptuous is
trying to write history now because all
of the parent all of the presidents who
were vilified when they were on office
Roosevelt Kennedy Truman Eisenhower
Reagan and on a looking back in
hindsight those guys did some stuff
right and whether it is the Iraq war the
response to 911 or the response to AIDS
clearly this president has done more for
global health than any president in
history not only in the area of AIDS but
also in the area of malaria and in many
other areas too I'm sure that'll be part
of his legacy but you can't write a
legacy in them in in the middle